well I had the opportunity to give a
detailed introduction to today's speaker
yesterday and I'll shorten it up but I
didn't want to take the opportunity to
actually describe our guests
Maxwell Bennett is the University chair
professor of neuroscience in the
department of physiology and the
scientific director of the brain and
mind Research Institute at the
University of Sydney Australia he has
for those of you yesterday to hear the
more detailed description it has an
illustrious career in neuroscience
particularly pioneering ATP and
non-colored nurture cholinergic synapses
in the autonomic nervous system has
worked on many aspects of neuroscience
and now as at this institute it is able
to supervise and be part of an end
basically diverse neuroscience research
program in all areas of neuroscience
from the peer experimental to the
population level and Applied Psychology
yesterday I opened up by pointing out of
course that we have a corporeal body and
a range of psychological capacities
remembering feeling perceiving and
thinking then I took the story back to
its basic roots going back 3000 BC and
indicated to you the way in which the
Egyptians had developed a concept of
what it means to be human
in terms of a tripartite concept which
had rationality it had in the second
part the emotions and in the third part
it had things to do with the vegetative
state nutrition the need for energy and
then I developed that story and showed
you by means of this table here the
wiring which had have been taken up by
successive generations over around about
4000 years the way they've been taken up
in the 8th century by Homer developed by
Plato who still has such an enormous
effect on the concepts developed in this
in the Western world but the genius
Aristotle and then I left out of the
equation the person whose shadow we
definitely work under at present
Descartes because as you can see by the
table Descartes made a very big change
because he confiscated all of this this
story this tripartite story here here
very clear he confiscated it and brought
it down to this concept of consciousness
and he's defined consciousness of
everything that you experience within
you like the stream of consciousness of
Virginia Woolf who I've been riding on
lately thought which was related to the
nouse the mind he regarded as a special
kind of attribute of the soul as he was
thinking of in these terms but
consciousness implied that we had not
only thought which was buried in
consciousness but the capacity for
perception for feelings emotions they
were capacities that belonged to the
body and were open to physiological
investigation they weren't something of
an ephemeral nature at all they were
mechanistic things which nevertheless
the mind or in particular consciousness
had the capacity to make contact with so
we have thought which was a special
category not belonging to the Corporal
but these other aspects which had been
divided into nutritive and sensitive and
what-have-you these other aspects were
aspects of the body undergoing the
capacity for mechanistic analysis which
really created the subject of physiology
so if that's the caddis how did he
conceived of consciousness itself how do
we break that down and my colleague
Peter hacker and I looked at this a
little bit recently and what he did
really was say well look when it comes
to things like memory this is open to
straight mechanistic analysis physiology
if you like it's a consciousness of
facts were you ruminating on facts at
one kind of another you remembering
these facts or for example much more
perhaps easily to be grasped is you have
perceptual consciousness I'm aware now
that Gary is not taking any notice of me
but is right
in his book okay so I'm my perception is
caught by the fact that out of the side
of my visual field his hand was moving
and so I become conscious of that and so
on and so forth
emotions conscious the fact that I'm a
little stressed now in having such an
audience in front of me to take him what
I'm trying to say here so there were
these various kinds of aspects of
conscious being our our winds been
caught by different kinds of activities
which spilled out by those little clouds
here however what Peter and I did in our
book which is now 13 years old
philosophical foundations of
neuroscience was we bundled these things
together and said that really you can
consider them the way that emerged in
the 19th century as a form of what we
call intransitive conscious status are
you conscious at all or are you
unconscious have you been hit by a car
have you had an anesthetic are you
asleep
which case you're unconscious so if
you're unconscious then clearly none of
these capacities are active at all
you're not conscious of Gary's hand
moving you're asleep so none of that is
actually occurring at all
well the question then of whether you
become unconscious or not unconscious
whether you have these specific levels
of consciousness is something which
actually developed historically in a
rather intriguing fashion because at the
beginning of the 17th century when dicot
was just getting going there was no such
word in the English language the word
consciousness does not appear in shake
could be whatsoever so where did it come
from well it comes of course from the
Latin it's Kearse I know and come with
so giving us the verb Conseco it comes
from that but it wasn't in the English
language at all when it gradually crept
into the English language around about
the middle of the 17th century it came
to mean that I have some special kind of
knowledge or information if you like
which I am pretty too and so is a
special friend of mine pretty too we are
the only ones who have this knowledge
and then it gradually evolved was the
to the 17th century in English and into
the 18th century to something which I am
pretty too alone
no one else knows about this and then it
evolved further by around about 1750 it
evolved to mean I am aware of the
information or of the kinds of
experiences I've had which are privy to
me in a very personal one which is
pretty much the way we say now that
you're unconscious because you're still
under the anesthetic that or you are
conscious that sort of thing however the
word being unconscious or been conscious
didn't actually occur in English until
about 1850 so you couldn't be
unconscious if you're a Brit until
around about 1850 because the word
didn't exist to describe that so I'm
going to take that word though the way
we now use it of course I'm conscious
not capable of any of these capacities
at all and I'm going to elaborate for
you that why it has been thought of in
terms of the relationship between the
Corporal activities as their Committees
of your body and whether you are
conscious or unconscious some of you be
very disappointed that I'm not going to
spend some time on this one or that one
well these are lectures or shall I say
presentations on their iron but let's
deal with this very interesting one to
say the least of whether you are
conscious or unconscious at all now for
Descartes was very straightforward of
course the the whole matter was that
that you are a conscious or unconscious
weather and depending on the
relationship between this bit of
corporal as I mentioned yesterday the
pineal gland and the Spiritist substance
in the ventricles where all those
wonderful things happened that allowed
you to enter the mind itself and these
issued now and I rather love this I kind
of mentioned them again
these little Wiggles here represent what
Aristotle said was impossible that is
you cannot have the Corporal interacting
with the Spiritist by having a little
wheels there has to be some rigid
process and you can't reach to such
unlike substances or my favorite
philosopher knows it would say it's
impossible to bridge them that must go
together hand in hand in
but there could be no cause of
relationship between them at all ah we
got rid of that very easily because
while Descartes was still alive it was
shown that the Pioneer gland isn't there
at all
pineal gland is actually hanging outside
the ventricles and therefore the whole
yarn collapsed however it hasn't
collapsed as far as more recent
investigations are concerning with your
conscious or unconscious and what's
going on in the body in the Corporal so
we go now to a diagram which I use a
couple of times yesterday and this is
the diagram which really goes back to
the Silman lectures of Sherrington in
the aisle around about nineteen hundred
and six 170 and I mentioned to you that
at that stage that we knew a lot about
that's part of the brain here concerned
with hearing a lot about this part of
the brain here concerned with vision
here with being able to move your limbs
and here being able to experience
whether you've got an itchy skin or
whether your hand is up here somewhere
that kind of sensory information and
then I went on to show you that and when
we come to very serious shall I say
simple cognitive things like
distinguishing between whether there's
numerals on that wall over there or
whether in fact this alphabet on their
wall over there then we start engaging
this large area that's Sherrington knew
nothing about - all of these these areas
here we start to engage those in a quite
a complex why that is there isn't a
module here related to you distinguish
between numerals and the alphabet it's
distributed all over the place this sort
of activity and I finished on a rather
sound note by saying I found it all
rather disappointed because as a
consequence of that distributed activity
and the lack of modularity there we have
no grip we have no synoptic view of
where we're going in research on the
Corporal in relationship to our
capacities or in relationship to whether
we're conscious or unconscious well I'm
going to invert that in this
presentation I don't want to be kicked
out of Yale I'd rather be someone who's
thought up and it reasonably carload so
I'm going to actually take out
stories now and show you that we are now
I think in a region investigation on the
Brian which I'm very glad as I said to
Bob earlier this morning I'm very glad
to be alive
to actually see it going on what is
going on in all this gray matter here is
something I touched on before namely
that there's lots of things called
neurons in there and what we're going to
inquire into is one of the neurons doing
when you become unconscious now what is
the relationship between the corporeal
neurons and the capacity to be conscious
or unconscious with understood to that
level of investigation throughout my
presentation well of course as I said
last time to you and someone will be
board this because you've already seen
it we have these neurons here making up
the cortex antal the cortex here and
they connect with each other by these
little junctions here the synapse one
day and one there there's about 10
raised to the power 15 of these for
those of you who like those sorts of
numbers and one part of a cortex which
might have these neurons in it can
connect to another part of the cortex
which is a long wire I so from there all
the way over there it connect via these
processes the axons of the neurons
projecting in the white matter which I
showed you yesterday goes for a long way
and then they come back into the gray
matter again and connect up so we've got
long-range connections going all over
the place and our inquiry is what's
going on here
when you become unconscious now I'm now
going to develop a third to embarrass my
host Bob Shulman and show you that one
of the two major ways of coming to grips
with this in a way which i think is very
exciting gives us an overview of our
subject it leads us down paths which the
next generation will certainly have a
lot of fun following up and if I have
anything to do with it I will also have
a lot of fun following it up and that is
we can now measure the activity in a
region of this like this here we can now
measure quantitatively with great
accuracy now I'm not talking about
what's going on here I'm talking about
this part of the brain here what's going
on versus a that part of the
Brian when you become unconscious and
the way it works out is by means of this
little diagram which will throw some of
you off your seat here this here shows
you one of those silences so this is
about one thousandth of a millimeter
across here and it's making a connection
onto another neuron here another
thousand for the NA meter and there's a
third little bit this is the neuron cell
body which is about one-twentieth of a
millimeter and it sends out its axon
running around here like this and then
it ends up making one of these little
silences and I've just increased the
magnification here and blown it up here
to blow you out of your c2 all this
color and things going off so what did
Sherman and his colleagues his wonderful
colleagues Doug and for me do well what
they've shown over the last quite a few
years now is that you can measure the
actual electrical activity here not by
putting electrodes and all those fancy
things in there but by going out at this
one there's a lots of electro activity
associated with the workings of these
things here and when there's electric
activity
there's movements of particles from in
the extracellular space here into the
neuron now the neuron can only take so
many of these particles which are cool
ions before it will cease to work I mean
it just gets loaded down so you've got
to get them out you've got to get them
out otherwise the whole system will just
collapse you don't want to get them out
you have to have pumps so there's little
pumps all over the place getting these
ions out in order to get pumping down
you have to have energy you have to have
some form to drive the pumps just the
same as a mechanical pump out the road
there you've got to have for controlling
or something like that some form of
energy so what happened in the largest
here in the aisle was to develop a
technique for measuring this energy
that's actually been developed it's very
simple actually the technique no hope to
offend my host but I think it's
reasonably simple so if you can measure
this energy you're actually getting a
measure of all the electron activity
therefore if you're becoming unconscious
what happens to all this activity can be
given
theory I think quantitative measure by
looking at this energy without doing all
this fancy electrical stuff and what you
get is one of the two most informative
diagrams I think that's floating around
at present in trying to relate the
Corporal to consciousness or
unconsciousness and I'm afraid that's
our graph again and I changed this now
and it take you slowly through this
because I think it's a it's a Bobby
Dazzler here on the vertical axis here
I've amount of energy if you live in a
particular part of the Brian and what
I'm showing you here is that up here
you've got normal wakefulness so you've
got all those activity in the brains
going on churning awhile and so we'll
just call that 100% energy level of your
life as you go to sleep normal sleep
this energy level drops bit by bit drops
until you get down to a level which is
about 50% so down here when you're fully
asleep what we call slow-wave sleep down
here when you're unconscious half of
your brain activity you're still going
for that out so you've still got 50% of
your brain working when you're fully
unconscious if we want to have another
angle on this and you take a general
anaesthetic then the same thing happens
you take the general anaesthetic and you
gradually see the amount of energy been
utilized by the brian drop and drop and
drop until it gets to about 50% and then
all this continues going here so that's
very interesting because it's during
this drop here as you become unconscious
that the electro activity is falling out
also if you look at behavior that is
what does it mean to become unconscious
it's very revealing because there's any
anesthetist will tell you what is
happening is first of all your speech
becomes blue you then got the talk very
clearly at all secondly you can't
respond to a request the audition starts
to get fouled up thirdly if you're
pinched you stop moving your arm away
straight away from the side of the pain
as a consequence of the pinch so all
these things the lesion deception
matters of that kind giving a thoughtful
response
a request or question all starts to
become blurred and they don't come all
blurred at the one time some you start
the lose before others of these
different capacitors so if you follow
those down as you lose this until you
have fully lost all these capacities and
your unconscious that is a very
interesting insight into what's going on
in the brain as you become unconscious
so big question is is these certain
areas of the brain which are critical in
terms of dropping their activity down
like this for you to become unconscious
whereas other parts of the brain don't
drop down at all is there any particular
parts of the brain those parts of the
brain would be Descartes pineal gland we
would at last sold the problem because
here we have the part of the brain the
Corporal which when it becomes
relatively inactive we become
unconscious so this is the magic little
bit we want a corner so there's one kind
of interesting kind of angle there the
next kind of angle which is of great
interest is what is going on here now I
reckon that the next generation
including me of course will work out
what's going on here
along the lines that are just indicated
but what's going on here is something
which might interest someone who is
completely wrapped up in Freudian
analysis I mean this is the true
subconscious down here and we haven't
got a clue really what's going on
certainly memory is going on if you're
looking parts of the brain responsible
for you remembering things then what we
can see during this period here but
those parts of the brain are very active
and that there are different ways which
are can be fairly precisely delineated
as associated with you remembering some
event when you were awake so that is
certainly going on but that's a very
small part of the total activity which
is still going on in this period here so
I leave you with this delectable
Freudian area here which know that when
some people already having a gallery
that but it's so abominable invalid that
I want to bother you with telling you
about
up here you'll notice that this is line
here is not sitting on one it's sitting
a little bit different to one a little
bit more and that's because when you are
fully awake you don't have a set amount
of activity in whether you're Brian the
activity in the brain is actually
varying a bit all the time
up and down here it's not very much on
the average is about this but it's
varying up and down by about 10% that's
going to be important at the moment I
mean what's going on with all this
variation when were fully or what so I
think you can see that this diagram
opens up a whole range of activities
which are quantitatively capable of
being analyzed in terms of what is going
on with the activity of the brain and
which parts of the brain as you lose
consciousness and of course if you want
to go that far what is going on in the
context of things in the subconscious
and they eat if you like what's going on
there now I'm going to leave that
hanging there for a moment because I'm
now going to come from this problem of
when you become unconscious from a
slightly different angle an angle which
we looked at to some extent yesterday
and it's this all right if we can look
at different parts of the brain that
we've colored them in here in different
ways and we've given them different
numbers and if we look at the change in
energy the previous diagram we might
find this part of the brain here is
losing that energy as you become of an
activity of your life as you become
unconscious whereas this part here is
not very much well as I said earlier
that would be very interesting and this
is looking at the side of the brain here
this is looking in the middle of the
brain here that's a section down the
middle there and we can look at all
these different areas in that Y but what
are most interesting why I'm looking at
the areas is using the technique which
Sherrington first described here at Yale
100 years ago and it's the technique I
introduced you to last time the upturned
flask picnic where what Charenton did
just to remind you was he exposed the
brain here of a chimp and put this
upturned flask full of fluid on top of
the exposed cortex there and he reasoned
that just as the human group of shown
now but if in fact the neurons are very
active just here then they'll need more
energy that made glucose for example off
the energy providing elements which can
only be provided by the blood stroke so
if their blood streaming
increases it increase in blood volume
and blood flow here it would indicate
that the neurons here were very active
because they needed that energy that
could've goes their oxygen and therefore
if the diameter of the blood vessels
increases there'll be the volume here
will up the fluid level here will rise
indicating that the blood vessels are
becoming gorged with blood supply this
energy and this is the famous technique
which he developed in which is now
called functional magnetic resonance
imaging so my question is if we apply
that flask there at the back of the
brain and at the same time we take
another flask and we put it up here at
the front of the brain what kind of
fluctuations that I've seen because I
showed you before that these
fluctuations going on all the time in
the activity of the brain well these are
the sort of fluctuations that they see
when you do that experiment here are the
fluctuations this is time here and up
here if you like this energy or whatever
else you like and here in yellow is the
front of the brain and here in blue is
the back of the brain and here in black
is an intermediate area now you might
say oh well that's jolly good what's all
that mean well what it reflects is that
as I said to you about 10% of the
activity of the brain all the time is
fluctuating up and down these these
profiles here are measures of that
fluctuation so this is the front of the
brain fluctuating there's the back of
the brain fluctuating in the middle of
the brain fluctuating here now the
extraordinary thing is I'm not going to
bore you by taking you through all this
very carefully but if you look at that
you'll find that some in some cases
those fluctuations are in phase with
each other that is they can be
correlated does the extraordinary thing
is that something up here is actually
increasing its activity
in line with that is in the sciences
with activity at the back eight miles
away as far as cortical projections are
concerned so we've got the back of the
brain now in this example going along
correlated in its activity with the
front of the burn
now that's very initial and that really
implies that there's some kind of
activity going on which binds the front
and the back of the brain together now
this is not someone who's doing anything
the person who's got these class one up
the front a brought up the back here
doing these measurements it's not
reading Shakespeare but not mowing the
lawns they're just sitting down doing
nothing in particular but is there
quarter the junior wolf
stream-of-consciousness if you like
they're not doing anything particular
and yet these correlations are occurring
between different parts of the brain and
they reasonably recapitulated from one
time to another and from one patient or
one subject to another village this part
is correlated with that part and contra
to that this part over here is
correlated to this part here so there
are these kinds of activities going on
all together and you might say well so
what so what
well the so what part is first of all
how could this occur and I told you last
time that is yesterday carrot it can
occur and it can occur because of the
other great I think trying to put
technique that's come about in the last
several years this is her that native
resonance imaging technique which I
won't go into it but it allows us to see
the white matter tracks of the brine
that is we can see as I pointed out
yesterday the front of the brain is the
nose up there
here is a track the cingulum tract as
it's called and it connects the front
here all the way back here to the back
and there's another one here the
superior here disappear long term
sickness but cooks here all the way but
these ones going to the side not going
to the back here at all and here's other
ones and other ones not now all that
white matter that I showed you yesterday
is really these tracks so it's not
really something to be terribly
surprised about
but when activity increases here it also
increases in synchrony here because
they're connected to each other ones
draw it in the other one certain times
July now that's very interesting because
it's only a finite number of these well
it's not an infinite amount of things
going on connected rather than in
correlation there's just one connected
theater there another one blah blah blah
and it won't go through them all but
there's a certain set of these
correlations that are going on in the
activity of your Brian now let me pause
for a moment and say this that when it
comes to the way in which your nervous
system moves your limbs that was a great
mystery and I think perhaps the most
illuminating two periods in the whole
history of that was one was occurred
around the kind of Leonardo da Vinci
under sailors and what they did was to
show that instead of there just being
this massive muscle which is your leg
and just got to move it around like that
the first thing they showed was not
delineating that this is the factorial
of this is the gastrocnemius muscle and
that kind of thing
they delineate the nerves they show that
the massive sciatic nerve comes out of
here and that gives you all trouble with
your back pain
the massive sciatic nerve comes out it
and goes through the buttock goes down
there and then it breaks up into these
exquisite branches winder which goes
here one there one down there and the
femoral nerve and one down here and it
branches into little bits and and they
followed that meticulously particularly
Leonardo meticulously and so they
realized that since the nerve was
carrying the spirit of substance of
really of Galen since it was carrying
the substance responsible to move into
muscles then the muscles were really in
a sense being delineated functionally by
the breaking up of the nerds it wasn't
the muscles came first then the nurse
hooked in it's the branching of the
nerves which shared the functionality
and break up of the muscles of him I
mention all that as analogous to the
browser because it's as if this kind of
thing here working out where all the
nerves are going is analogous to the
situation where we have the Nerds that
sadek nervous
breaking up and ending up in these
different parts of the Lin and then we
come along and we look at the gray
matter and see which bits of gray matter
that is the same clumps of neurons which
clumps of neurons belong here or muscle
if you like we've got the analogy to be
pushed further at which clumps are here
and which so we're breaking it up I
think in an analogous way to what
happened way back then in the 14th and
15th century and it's extremely
illuminating we've got something to hang
on to like the geneticists I believe do
we've got a structure we've got an
armature so the armature is there
physically and in addition to that we've
got activity it's not just there
structurally it's there functionally
because we know that this particular bit
here which I keep emphasizing the
cingulum that it's connecting there and
there and those two areas are correlated
all the time in activity and it's the
salon where the other structures in that
particular part of the brain but again
you might say so what well the so what
part is this how does this impact on the
question of you becoming unconscious and
it impacts in this way that at present
it would appear that as you become
unconscious as in fact you drop down for
that 100% level of activity down to the
50% level activity when you're
completely out to it that these
correlations are lost
of course the tracks are lost you don't
lose whole nerves when you go to sleep
and then putting us back again when
you're woke up in the morning they're
still there but the correlated activity
that is the fact that this one is taking
off and driving this one up here that in
some part of the brain or the wall parts
that is lost now that is shown here in
the next slide what I'm showing you here
is that we've got it's not coming in
that you're the original coming here it
was just some other than what's going on
there so that's that's a red bird that's
red that's red red red where that black
is there now what that region there is
the frontal region which is very active
you know normally awake and this is the
back region which is very active too and
the redness referred or the blackness
refers to the extent of correlation sire
the interesting thing is that when you
go from here and you take the anesthetic
and you become unconscious to there
you'll notice that this black region is
gone virtually God that is this is no
longer correlated with that it is when
you're awake and it isn't when you're
asleep now nothing's been stripped out I
emphasize now axons have been lost or
anything like that but clearly part of
the reason why the amount of activity in
the brain is dropping about 50% is
because these kinds of ways in which one
part of the brain does driving another
father Brian and some cases have been
lost and that is a as a consequence of
that you are becoming unconscious under
the conditions of our state a very nice
experiment to drive this one home is
indicated here and that is you take an
electro the stimulating electrode and
when you don't take a stimulator but you
effectively take a stimulating electrode
and this is a normal of both person and
you stimulate that frontal part of the
brain but when you do that you
immediately stimulate this part of the
battery of the part which is normally
correlated with it and the resting
conditions but then this case here this
is not a condition of just normally
arising this is being driven at the back
by you stimulate in the front and of
course as I keep emphasizing there are
axons connecting those two so it's
natural that if you drive that then the
axons will lead to this being driven
when the person has had down a set it it
won't work you now stimulate this region
here and of course you activate the
region where you're stimulating but this
is no longer activated at the back it's
become functionally disconnected even
though the structural connections here
those big nerve trunks are of course
still in plants this is someone who is
unconscious I have been anesthetized
this is someone who is conscious so that
emphasizes the fact that there seem to
be these very interesting car
licensed going on now I can give you
another example of this and this is more
natural and this is you falling asleep
so again I'm giving you the activity in
correlate at the front here with that at
the back here and then as you fall
asleep come down here then gradually
what happens is it's no longer correlate
but back is still active in is
correlated with other activities but
it's not correlated with the front
correlations with the front of God so
again that 50% drop in the activity the
brain in sleep as in anesthesia is
showing you the results that what
happens and I'm giving that to you now
in a little diagram here is the front of
the brain meet your front if the front
here is the part at the back here this
is the structural and functional
connection family when you're awake but
when you fall asleep that's gone not
structurally but it functionally the
synapses which are mediating that
connection are turned off and you are
now unconscious now you can develop this
theme in many different words you can
for example take someone who's caught in
that terrible condition of being in the
vegetative state that is there someone
who for example there many famous crisis
there is one in America called Karen
Kelly who went to a lovely party as
people do when they're 21 years of age
and took both knitting theater mean as
well as vodka and got herself into a lot
of trouble ended up in the vegetative
state where your course you need quite
often you need a respirator
not all ones need a respirator it's very
little activity that can be recorded
from the from the cortex at all now
under those conditions you can get
yourself into a lot of trouble with
these kinds of phenomena as shown here
now this will really throw you out but
here's the normal connection between the
front and the back that yellow line
there indicates it and in the case of
the vegetative state it's completely
gone and it as is every other connection
in terms of these functional connections
of ongoing activity nothing has been
recording at all so certainly such a
person is unconscious
and what I'm suggesting to you is what's
happening here is that we have these
wonderful structures here which we are
gradually sorting out
they are mediating these ongoing
activities all the time when we're fully
awake the connections here the synaptic
connections here or there I gradually
turned off as you become unconscious
whether it's judo general anaesthetic or
whether you're going to sleep or whether
it's under conditions of the tragedy of
being in the vegetative state so when I
started out with was this diagram which
I gave you yesterday as well here are
all the neurons throughout the front and
here all the neurons up the back and
they're connected to each other I gave
you that big tract connected one to the
other going through here this is
functionally looked like it's been
turned off during the conditions of your
gradually falling asleep before generous
thing and it's consequence of being
turned off you become unconscious
now I haven't emphasized the fact that
there are a number of other such
networks if you like which do not turn
off when you go to sleep or become
unconscious as a consequence about
understood it but certainly this one
between the front and the back looks
like it is been turned off and here's a
concomitant corporal challenge giving
you the basis of you being unconscious
I'm going to finish with my second last
PowerPoint which is showing you
something which you're going to be
horrified that or that is this here are
neurons in a group and they're over
there as another set of neurons in the
group and they're connected by these
long projections going the case I've
kept emphasizing of the front and the
back and all I've done here is to do
that diagrammatically here's a bunch of
neurons doing all their things and
here's another bunch of neurons doing
their things and forget about that
I mean connecting the front of the brain
to the back of the brain with its lovely
tract of newer axons connecting four to
there and what I'm saying to you is that
if you just set that system up you can
do it quite easily map
it'll rip a lot it'll set up firings all
the time and this one will drive that
one and everything will be married and
then if you gradually turn off these
connections you'll find that the
activity the correlated activity here
naturally have drops because they're no
longer very well connected but also
their intrinsic activity drops not just
the correlations but the amount of
activity they will drop at that 50% that
is it'll drop about the same amount as
you see dropped according to the energy
measurements I showed you in that graph
as you go unconscious as you become
unconscious these activities drop by
about that amount 50% because the
correlations are gradually dropped one
is no longer driving in the harbor and
the whole thing settles down and you're
no longer conscious at all the story
I've taken you through here in the last
two presentations is this we started off
with the the idea of the ventricular
theory of the Corporal that is that our
capacities to remember field perceive
and think of all the risk that reside in
the Spiritist substance found there in
three ventricles one for memory one for
thinking and one third emotions and
sensations for development and then we
came to the argument that Descartes had
that we can pull this together if we
talk about consciousness and have
consciousness interacting with the
vitreous up to this far this wonderful
arrangement of the pineal gland and the
Wiggles then the whole story was shifted
as I mentioned to you yesterday when
just about the time of Descartes death
Willis and Christopher rain and oxford
showed that there was no correlation
between where blood flow went and where
the ventricles were that is to say the
venturers could not have the magic
psychic substance which went down nerves
and controlled your muscles because the
blood vessels which carry the psychic
substance from a high
you having breathed in the ether the
ether going to the heart as our astata
love argued had been turned into to
nuuma and then the cycling substance
once the stuff had been pumped up into
the brain into the vitreous and then it
went out the vitreous down the nerves
that was not a gala because the blood
vessels had nothing to do with the
ventricles at all
it was the cortex now we were at in
these contemporary times in the first
part of the 21st century is in fact the
consciousness is dependent you notice I
say dependent because the the book with
Peter hacker philosophical foundation it
made this distinction at length it is
not the Corporal Wow the consciousness
is clearly dependent on the corporeal
that is the workings of this cortex and
where we are now is saying that that is
correlated that consciousness is
correlated with the correlated activity
in certain parts of the brain and if
that is lost then we become unconscious
but I emphasize the fact that there are
other parts that Brian that are
undergoing correlated activity and that
is not apparently lost at all would you
become unconscious and I hope it
wouldn't be because when you become
unconscious as you know because of the
diagram I showed you 50% of the activity
the brain is still going on mmm Freud
would have been very happy with that
result
Freud was really quite a genius I think
his greatest contributions where one he
could be regarded as one of the two
discovers of the neuron before cahal
freud to secta doubt and gyro one neuron
on its arm from the crustacean and that
was an extraordinary thing to have done
because it showed that in iran was an
isolated cell that as it wasn't
something in acid city and with
everything else can it do everything
else it did that certainly he partook in
some very important experiments
discovering the first an acidic cocoa or
proko
then he went astray and spend some time
developing our ideas about the
subconscious I think that's coming right
back in again now because of that fifty
percent that's hanging around all that
activity when you're fully unconscious
and we don't know what it's doing so in
summary then where are we with respect
to Charenton being here at yale a
hundred years ago well I've seen that
consciousness when conscious or
unconscious something which you aren't
weren't able to do until the 19th
century depends on the sustained
integrative actions of the cortex which
correlated activities these integrated
activities yesterday I've made some
comment about transient integrative
actions associated with you say
distinguishing between letters and
numbers on the screen or something like
that the concept here compared with
sharing Tain's great work which came out
of his yard lectures and you wait till
you read my book coming out of these
lectures his great work called the
integrative action of the nervous system
delivered as the Sillman lectures are
904 what Charenton had done is something
which is really very remarkable because
as i touched on yesterday sheridan
showed that walking locomotion like this
could be seen to be the integration of
specific modular reflexes the stretch
reflex that we effects associated with a
sudden tendon jerk which gives you that
kind of action of your foot sudden
flexor action extensor action in this
case the crossed extensive reflex
whereby you put one foot down and you
lift the other foot up and you hold that
against gravity he worked out these
reflexes and he put them all together
and showed how you would produce
locomotion walking and then he showed
finally that you could get this because
he took dogs and showed that their
spinal cord alone could allow them to
walk without the brain being involved at
all now you might say well that was a
wonderful piece of physiology it was
number two greatest pieces of physiology
in the 20th century
but until Sheraton the I grant which are
a stofflet put 2300 years earlier still
stood and that is that they must be a
spinal soul they must be a sold in the
spinal cord because we're able to walk
around like this and you can see other
animals and their brains not connected
to their spinal cord at all and they can
also walk around like your Chuck in the
yard and with this sort of thing so as
Aristotle had observed it lizards and
other animals including birds and chores
now you can continue on their merry way
with no connections between the head and
the spinal cord so there must be a soul
in the spinal cord now that's a very
interesting kind of point because many
great physiologist in the 19th century
thought that was true that there was a
solvent until Sherrington there is no
logical basis to rejecting the fact that
there's a soul in the spinal cord as a
consequence of Sheratons experiments and
what will be interesting to see in the
next 20 years of my research is whether
in fact the concept of a soul in the
brain also gradually is put aside it's
no longer emphasized at all it's no
longer a major issue about how we have
the Corporal related to the mind and
consciousness because so many of the
integrative actions that we're now
working on had actually come true in the
ways in which I have sketched very
briefly
thank you
I've got this wonderful gadget there
though yeah that's a terrific question
I'm the last person who asked me that
question was someone know through our
dialogue at our national university and
his name was the Dalai Lama and and we
don't we actually don't have an answer
to that and it could easily be sorted
out there are difficulties and that is
there's a lot of noise when you shower
head into one of these gadgets and it's
not easy to meditate but that kind of
noise going on a lot of work not a lot
some work has been done with magnetic
looking at gray matter changes and
people who do a lot of meditation and
there are certain arguments there about
the effects on the dry matter but
beneficial effects on the gray matter
but I don't know at present of any
measurement of this kind but it could be
done with these energy measurements
which Bob's average began a I think
could be performed in this case
absolutely it's on my list
absolutely well you're nearly there with
the key question you're hovering around
the key question it was amazing I had a
class I had at the University of Sydney
before our Cannavaro at this talk and
was full of psychiatrists and
neurophysiologists and all the rest of
it and I I said in my talk there's one
key question here and I had one I'm
gonna ask I'm not gonna give it to you
now and now in our secretion because the
very end the guy asked the question was
electrical engineer I was very proud as
that was my first degree at liquid
engineering the answer to your question
to come to the point is that the key
question of course is you've got the
physical acts on tracks there the nerves
going and yet they become non-functional
in some regions when you become
unconscious how does that happen now
when I think this was violent because I
put it at the beginning of this year in
a pipe
in plus one one possibility is that
there are regions the brine down here
which project in to the regions of these
synapses and control their function I'll
just show it to you now
thank you so much for the Christian as
it gives me an excuse to Scott so I come
back to this this is one part of the
brine of the front and this is another
part of the back the side and here is
the big cingulum set of trunk at axons
connecting them to if there's another
part of the brain here called the basal
nucleus apartment so that nucleus
aligner and it projects up on top of
these are the synaptic projects there
and if this stops working these stop
work so it needs the co-operative
activity of this thing down here to keep
these sign up does act if this doesn't
work then these don't look like they
working too well at all so you've got
structurally you still got all those
axons in place but functionally they're
not doing so well so the question is
next when you go to sleep and there's a
general anesthetic or what have you are
you turning this off and then it's no
longer doing that but the sleep argument
and I'm sorry to involve you in
physiology with a sleep argument your
circadian rhythm where you fall asleep
and then my circadian with has been over
the place since I came from Sydney so if
you've got the circadian rhythm which
determines so much of whether you're
going to be a happy person or a
depressed person depending on how much
sleep you're getting might have you that
circadian rhythm is come from that sleep
rhythm is controlled from down here in
the brainstem in the part beer which has
been recognized for some 50 years and
that that goes to here so the scalene
rhythm during say natural sleep will
turn this off which in turn can turn it
off so this structural element is via
but the correlations here can no longer
act and furthermore therefore since
there's no longer interaction between
these two the Manor activity here drops
about fifty percent does that give you a
hazy idea you're blurring over our I
can't see
yeah don't blind it yeah I can't
remember exactly when it was done but in
the last couple years this group of
neuroscientists is now - I was right
that's a that's a big package that'll
cost you $50 that's the I think it's
reminded now my philosophical
foundations of neuroscience as I love it
at all good book shopped that I mean an
assault had no trouble with that
question or dream I mean the dog runs up
you know you come home it runs up down
the hallway knows you're there remembers
who you are and okay now it's time to go
for a walk and you pick up the lead and
jumps of labia it's got memory
I couldn't the site and that's a
component you could say I've argued back
and you can go through these I mean you
can go through a motion you go there's
no big deal involved it's not as if
we're dealing with some spiritual
numerals no no no no no no these aren't
laughable loser loser no no a lot of it
is my lunch from macaque monkeys
actually I'm afraid this little anecdote
there
Bertrand Russell says you've got to be
very careful about to run out lower
animals because to a halt aetherium a
lower animal is actually a centipede I
mean it just depends where you're out of
the hierarchy and it's got all these
bits and pieces array right this
correlation using what the rats Brian
important for the human Brian malice and
so absolutely absolutely absolutely I
mean it's very fascinating to see these
things are caring in the in the other
species of the lower species the other
species yeah
I haven't got my glasses on for me so I
didn't realize it was you otherwise I
wouldn't have asked you so I'm caught
are you talking about Spinoza oh okay
okay
this is master Nate become yeah
absolutely
yeah yeah of course yeah
I it depends I don't want to get
involved here in front of his audience
with what it is an epiphenomenon table I
don't agree with you that's necessarily
an epiphenomenon and I think I know
where you're coming from I thought you
got a slightly different question but I
don't think that's necessarily
predominant it might be but I don't
think it necessarily is because of the
energy arguments at all
where I thought the question I thought
you're going to put to me is a nasty one
and that is that is that I was a little
bit shallow saying at least that of the
26,000 papers that were published in the
air that I talked to yesterday and those
who attended that talk yesterday might
have left in a semi dismal state about
my reflections about where we're going
in terms of understanding the workings
of the cortex in relationship to our
psychological abilities today's
presentation has been more a bullet
because I think we are in a situation
where are lots of interesting techniques
are available when it comes to the
correlations this depends on certain
algorithms which have difficulties with
them and I won't go into the
technicalities of that but this has to
be worked evidence the in number of
modes for example in the principal just
in the in the principal element kind of
algorithm that sort of thing these have
to be cleaned up and if it turns out
that when we get stuck into it things
start to get messy or then we're in bad
shape but right now people are looking
at that that is for example the end made
routine and changing the number in from
6 or 10 up at 60 or 80 as we've been
talked about the other day and it's
being investigated and things haven't
all together fallen apart by any means
although there are caveats there so I'm
not going to carry on with too much of
audience but I've certainly got myself
well out of depression over these issues
of how the brain works with respect to
our psychological capacities yeah
it's a lower 50% it's the first 50% it's
the one that doesn't drop when you fall
asleep it's not 50% absolutely
absolutely well I mentioned the fact
that we've got good evidence that the
memory system is going on very well
indeed when you are in total sleep so
it's that 50% but that is doing some
extraordinary things and we haven't got
a handle on them I don't know we're
going to have except remember
I'm sorry these are let me be explicit
because I'm sorry to giving this to you
because it it it does confabulate a
little bit but at the same time I needed
to leave you in a state where
correlations as a matter of this and not
mysteries we're not back into the
psychic new murican I wanted to keep it
away from that so to be explicit their
neurons okay they're excitatory neurons
actually they give us a little cumin
these are inhibitory neurons down here
they're connected to each other so this
is a circuit of neurons ripping along
and there's another one there another
circle here on dripping along but here
we have this region of the brain
connected to that region their brain by
these things so these are the nerves
that's that long trunk which I showed
you earlier which is connecting one side
to the other
let me see if I can show it to them
they're out so that's that okay you got
that so they are those those sorts of
things so they're not neuron to say
they're the long protrusions the neurons
called the axon connecting one to go is
that answer you
about going back to the diagram we go
here yeah
these represent those trunks there's
long axons yeah these things here that
and that actually should talk about
later because you're looking yeah well
this is the white matter here that's all
the white man yeah that I'm thank you
for putting it explicitly that's that's
very important that's the white man you
may remember from yesterday I showed
you're darn right you haven't got there
now which shows you the last a map on
volume of the cortex is white matter
remember the huge amount of white
underneath a little bit of gray matter
on the top some of us had more gray than
others but it's not much compared by
volume for the white map
now wait a second - it perfect after
fifty dollars at all good book shot what
I didn't say that
what I'm saying is that if you lose
consciousness these things are happening
okay I didn't say these things caused in
it I said that as these things drop out
okay die are correlated with the fact
that you're losing consciousness that's
a very important distinction
in the top there you've got to be very
careful here very careful there is a
world expert in this room on the gut and
on the enteric nervous system and that's
me that's where I did my PhD I wrote a
book on it on the enteric nervous system
so tread carefully other people have put
this to me as well fact the density of
neurons in the enteric plexuses is
higher than that of the spinal cord or
in the frontal lobes is incredibly hard
but now in either Narva has correlated
these kinds of networks that I'm talking
about in the cortex in the gut with the
loss of consciousness the experiment has
to be done it'll be very interesting
what the result was I got out from that
pretty smoothly I thought